the following is the balance sheet of
first Superior Bank and so let's here on
the asset side it has 200 dollars of
reserves and 1800 dollars of loans so
it's total assets are two thousand
dollars and then that should be the same
as its liabilities and equity and we see
here that it has two thousand dollars in
demand deposits that's a liability
because people can come to the bank and
say hey I want that money
these are checkable deposits so they
could even try to withdraw that money
and since all of that two thousand
dollars is on the liability side there
is no equity right over here these two
should sum up to two thousand dollars
the same as you have on your assets I'd
assume that the required reserve ratio
is ten percent and just as a review
that's the percent of deposits that the
bank needs to keep as reserves and we
can see that it's at that reserve ratio
right now it has two thousand dollars in
deposits and so it needs to keep ten
percent adds reserves ten percent of two
thousand dollars is two hundred dollars
so it's at its minimum reserves already
Part A says what is the dollar value of
new loans that first superior bank can
make explain pause this video and see if
you can figure that out yourself
well as I just mentioned this Bank is
already at its minimum or reserves it's
already loaned out as much as it could
if you get two thousand dollars in
deposits and you have a ten percent
reserve ratio that means you can loan
out ninety percent of that two thousand
dollars and it has already loaned out
ninety percent of the two thousand
dollars so what is the dollar value of
new loans that first superior bank can
make well it's $0 zero dollars because
because already already at minimum
reserves minimum reserves alright let's
do Part B mr. Smith deposits one hundred
dollars of cash in a demand deposit
account in first Superior Bank calculate
the maximum amount of new loans that
first Superior Bank can now make so
pause this video again and see if you
can figure that out
well there's a couple of ways you could
think about it before mr. Smith makes
that deposit we already saw in part a
that first Superior Bank can't make any
new loans and so now if it gets a
hundred dollars of cash in a demand
deposit account because the reserve
ratio is 10% the bank needs to keep 10%
of that deposit as reserves and it can
loan out the other 90% so you could just
say well it can loan out 90% of that new
deposit and so it'd be 90% times 100
dollars which is equal to 90 dollars of
new loans another way that you could
think about it is after mr. Smith's
deposit the demand deposits right over
here goes to $2,100 and that increase in
liabilities is offset by an increase in
assets it just got a hundred dollars of
cash so the reserves go from $200 to
$300 now this point first superior Bank
is clearly above its minimum reserve
requirements 300 over 2100 is more than
10% so it can loan out some money how
much can it loan out what has to keep
10% of this 2,100 as reserves so it
needs to keep 210 right over here and so
that other 90 it could loan out and so
this could be 1890 and so it can make
$90 in new loans as a result of mr.
Smith's $100 cash deposit calculate the
maximum change over time in each of the
following in the banking system so part
one is loans so what's the maximum
change over time in the banking system
of loans pause this video and try to
figure it out well as we just said mr.
Smith by depositing 100 dollars first
superior bank can make $90 of loans so
that would be $90 of new loans but then
whoever they loaned that money to they
could then deposit that in a bank and
then that bank could the pot could loan
out 90% of that so then it would be zero
plus 0.9 times 90 now this bank that got
0.9
ninety dollars which is $81 it can then
loan out ninety percent of that so it's
going to be plus 0.9 times this was 0.9
squared times 90 and you just keep going
like this and then this gives us
essentially the equation for the
multiplier which you might have
memorized this is just going to be equal
to 90 times 1 / 1 - you could say this
0.9 or you could say this is the same
thing as 90 times 1 over the reserve
ratio which is 0.1 and 1 over 0.1 is 10
so this is going to be equal to $900 now
what is going to be the maximum change
over time in demand deposits pause this
video again and try to figure that out
when mr. Smith first deposits that
hundred dollars in cash at first
Superior Bank that creates $100
increased demand deposit here on first
superior banks balance sheet so that is
let me just write it this way so you
have 100 but then we already said that
first superior bank could loan out as
much as 90% of that and whoever they
loaned that to they could put all of
that into a bank as a demand deposit and
so that's going to be plus 0.9 times 100
and then that Bank could then loan out
0.9 times this and then whoever gets to
that loan that kid that could be they
could deposit into the bank creating a
demand deposit so plus 0.9 squared times
100 and it keeps going on and on and on
and you could just view this as this is
going to be equal to 100 times 1 over 1
minus 0.9 which is the same thing as 100
times 1 over the reserve ratio and so
this is just going to be 100 times 10
which is going to be $1,000
Part D as a result of mr. Smith's $100
cash deposit calculate the maximum
change over time in the money supply so
pause this video again and try to think
about it so you might be tempted to say
hey maybe that's just going to be the
same thing as
a total maximum change in demand
deposits but we have to be very careful
that first hundred dollars already
existed as cash in the money supply the
maximum change is everything else it's
this part right over here mr. Smith
deposits $100 in cash that's not new
money but then the bank can loan out 90%
of that so that's 90 dollars in new
money that someone could use to then
deposit in another Bank
and so that other Bank could then loan
out 90% of that 90 and we've seen this
drill before that was the exact same
calculation for part 1 right over here
this is just going to be equal to 90
times 1 over the reserve ratio which is
equal to $900 part-ii provide one reason
why the actual change in money supply
can be smaller than the maximum change
you identified in Part D pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
well there's actually two good reasons
why the actual change in money supply
might be smaller than what we just
calculated one reason is if banks decide
to keep more than the minimum reserves
so banks banks might keep more than
minimum minimum reserves so you could
imagine even though by law according to
this world they have to keep a reserve
ratio of 10% if on average the banks
decide to keep a reserve ratio of 20%
then every time they would loan out 80%
of whatever they get in deposits and so
you would have a lower number here
there's another world where the people
who get the loans don't deposit all of
that into the banking system so if you
wanted a second reason we've already
answered their question we've given one
reason but a second reason is people
might not deposit all of their funds in
the banking system so I will leave you
there